In cycle 44, we will be broadcasting the sixth instruction's result.
So this value 42 gets deposited in ROB6. We mark that as none.
We also broadcast the value 42 under the name ROB6, but nobody's waiting for
anything, so that kind of ends the broadcasting of that value.
Another thing that happens in cycle 44 is we're going to look at this,
instruction here and see whether we can commit, and
yes it can. We look at it because is the next instruction to commit, and
yes it can commit because it's done. so in cycle 44 we commit this. The way we
commit instructions again is take the value of 12, put it in register R1. Next,
look at the ROB entry for R1, and see whether it's pointing to us. It is not,
so we don't update the RAT to point here. Basically, the RAT still needs to
point here. Because that's still the most recent value for R1 that we will have.
And then we can free this ROB entry, and the commit point moves here.
So next cycle, we will be looking at this to commit. In cycle 45.
We will try to commit this instruction. It's done, so we can. we take 3,
put it in R3. We check the ROB entry for R3. It does point to us.
So we need to make RAT entry for R3 point back to the register 5.
Pretty much from now on, instructions that want to read R3 are actually going to
find it in the register file. And now that we have done that,
we can free this ROB entry. Now we're ready to move to Cycle 46.
In Cycle 46 we will try to commit this instruction. And it's ready to commit so
we can. We commit it by writing 36 into R1. And we check the RAT entry for
R1. Is it pointing to ROB 4? It is not, so you don't change the RAT.
And we have free this ROB entry. This concludes what has happened in cycle 46.
In cycle 47 we will try to commit this instruction. It's done, so
it's ready to commit. 47 is when we commit it.
We will deposit 33 into R4. We will check the right entry for R4.
Does it point to ROB5? Yes it does. Now it needs to point to the registry file.
And we free this ROB entry. Now we move to cycle 48,
where we try to commit this instruction. It's done so it can commit.
We deposit 42 into R1, so the final value of R1 is going to be 42.
We look at the, RAT entry for R1. Is it pointing to ROB6?
Yes, it is. So finally, the RAT entry is made to point to the register file.
So only now, instructions that want R1 are going to start looking at
the architecture register file. All the time until now, they would have found
the value in the ROB, or they would have had to wait for the value. With this,
we can finally free this ROB entry, and this concludes our example. So,
pretty much the [UNKNOWN] instruction is going to commit in cycle 14